I love doing intros hi hello welcome to
the other show I'm Chris I'm Sara we're
the creators of this other two and we're
here talking about Episode five with Ken
and Helene Andrew well in this episode
was directed by oh my Cornell husband
yeah we shot this episode days before
your lab this episode left on the next
day to go down to where we got married I
married that following Sunday we went on
a scout on Thursday the next week it's
so pretty out here makes me want to go
to a football game makes you want to sit
and watch a full football game no no I
guess it just makes me want to watch
Friday Night Lights I feel like a lot of
the show is you trying to measure
yourself against your little brother or
other people or am i doing well enough
or am i doing well enough fast enough
it's all a question we all ask ourselves
all the time yeah and so if I like
hopefully going back to the high school
helped bring that to a boil sort of I
guess especially for your character for
Carrie and even for Brooks and she
didn't get to go to high school really
she didn't have a typical upbringing I
named it so school and address but in
the writers room you would say like okay
and then this scene will be like on the
football field at night and the writers
room would be like for why what happens
there we like we don't know but there's
a big wide chatter I mean we did Fiddler
on the Roof and I think if I saw it now
I would I would still think it was good
did you play Tevye yeah so you were a
gay child playing a 40 year old Russian
peasant yes but but I think I pulled it
off in the writers room we were talking
a lot about like roles that you at the
time were like this is crazy that I was
cast as this but I was actually very
good cuz
no you weren't um I still think I was
pretty good at everything done Broadway
so you probably were good I I played in
ninth grade I played Daddy Warbucks and
I in ninth grade I didn't want to shave
my head and so I was like I'll wear a
bald cap we glued it on so I didn't like
you could feel that
sure you can feel you didn't want to rip
it so I would I did the whole play like
I had like a neck brace on in the moment
that year were you like I'm getting away
with this this the bald cap works or did
you know this is rough was terrific I
was I know one like some are
conversation but we do have a superstorm
it's because you want a very important
yeah that's cool so just let's what was
your worst well in high school in 1999 I
won best actress in New Jersey the best
actor in New Jersey was also in our play
and so is the Best Supporting Actress
because our drama teachers ran the
festival I do think it was edit out my
set up you see no I play soccer
perfect okay athletes make the best
singers meet me in the library in 20
minutes and bring your ball I was
telling you this story which is it was a
very pivotal moment in my deciding to
dive deeper into being an actor and I
was I played sports and I would and I
would be and I was in plays in school
and I would do both the varsity coach
cornered me in the locker room and he
was like Marino I was like yeah and he
goes you gonna play basketball this year
or do that acting ah and I was like
I'm gonna do the acting and then that
was it and I did quit I didn't play
basketball that next year and I just was
like and I still remember that that was
you know many many years ago but I
remember that moment and the decision of
like being like it was we were talking
about like it's a thing that you wrote
that you you have these moments of like
people who inspire you yeah we're people
who say things that like infuriate you
and motivate you to - but that's cool -
that made you be like that that didn't
be like oh I don't want to seem like a
I'll do basketball exactly I guess
because you were gay yeah I was gay
something like normally
[Laughter]
so this is where kids go after dances I
think just the losers where do the cool
kids go you guys have fun high school
dance story I only went to dances with
gay men right around the time that we
were going to prom I had a high school
boyfriend and we are very serious about
each other and we both were like in
musicals and plays and whatever together
and we each wrote a song for each other
and then we snuck into a church and play
them for each other in sobbed that is by
the way sound like it's from Dawson's
Creek I I didn't kiss a boy throughout
all of high school because I was in the
closet obviously and then my first kiss
with a boy I came out to one of my
friends from high school and my freshman
year of college I al instant message to
him and was like I'm gay and then he was
like me too and so then the next time I
was in my hometown we met up or like
well I don't think we're gonna be
together but we should we kissed each
other since we've never kissed so I made
us a drive to a half-built home and it
was half built I drove us there and then
I kind of like location scouted I was
like I think this room is big enough and
then I can sit down on do a step and we
made out there and it was great I guess
there's an outer I'll just say hi Eric
that was a great night and watch our
next episode
[Music]
you